Polarlichter haben die menschheit immer irgendwie fasziniert und sind auch. Heute noch geheimnisvoll doch die
Geisterhaften licht spielername haben die menschen früher vor allem angst eingeflößt denn die autoren genannten irrlichter
Galten als vorboten für unheil mittlerweile wissen wir das polarlicht dadurch sonnenwinde entstehen aber wie entstehen sie. Genau wie kann, man
Sie, am besten beobachten und welche gefahr geht von ihnen für uns menschen aus und welches geräusch machen sie
jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir waren das mal als fakt ist also die top fünf fakten über polarlichter hat fünf. So entstehen polarlichter
Wenn die sonne einen sonnenwind voller energie geladene teilchen protonen elektronen und helium atomen
Ausstößt braucht sonnenwind rund 18 stunden, um das magnetfeld der erde zu erreichen das wird auch, magnetosphäre
Genannt und hält die teilchen davon ab ganz an die erdoberfläche. Zu kommen weil sie vorher eben auf diese
magnetfeldlinien
Treffen diese sind in richtung norden ausgerichtet. Und hier wirkt
dann, sogenannte lorenz kraft die die elektrisch
Geladenen teilchen ablenkt und sie, um die magnetosphäre herum leitet zudem polen die energie geladenen teilchen verbinden
Sich dann mit den erd- eigenen atom. Und so entstehen die polarlichter das alles findet in rund 100 kilometern
Höhe stand also da wo der weltraum beginnt und deutlich über der wolkendecke
Während eines sonnensturms im oktober 2003 betrug die sonnenwind geschwindigkeit übrigens acht
und festhalten 2.000 kilometer pro sekunde
Fakt 4 darum sind polarlichter an den polen zu beobachten das magnetfeld der erde ist ja nicht
Kreisrund das haben, eine schule gelernt stattdessen hat es eine apfel form mit öffnungen
Oben und unten durchzogen eben von magnet verdienen und weil die elektronen auf grund ihrer ladung vor allem von den öffnungen der magnetfeldlinien
Angezogen werden werden sie zu den polen gelenk polarlichter sind übrigens an beiden enden der welt zu sehen
Und zwar zur selben zeit wenn
Sich also der himmel über norwegen verfärbt gibt es auch am südpol polar richter entsprechend nennt man sie dann auch
Nordlicht oder südlich, um polarlichter zu sehen braucht es, einen. Klaren. Und dunklen himmel wenn sie entstehen eben in rund 100 kilometern
Höhe je weiter man, sich von den
Polen entfernt unsere seltener werden polarlichter in deutschland sind sie nicht wirklich oft zu sehen doch wenn sehr starke
sorgen die stürme auftreten dann gibt sie auch bei uns, so etwa vier bis acht mal im jahr fakt sei
So entstehen die verschiedenen farben der polarlichter vielleicht wisst. Ihr dass die gewöhnlichen farben von polarlichtern. Blau rot
Und grün sind doch es gibt natürlich mischfarben wie etwa weiß gelb oder violett doch wie kommen die polarlichter an die
Einzelnen farben das hängt zum. Einen von der. Höhe ab in der die das ereignis
Stattfindet aber auch von den, unterschiedlichen bestandteilen der atmosphäre zwischen 150. Und 600 kilometern sorgen stickstoffatome für rote
und blaue farben in einer
Höhe von 80 bis 150 kilometern etwa da ist es sauerstoff der grüne polarlichter entstehen lässt fakt 2 so klingen
Polarlichter erst im vergangenen jahr hat ein forschungsteam aus finnland herausgefunden welche geräusche polarlichter produzieren sie
beschreiben es wie ein kurzes
Klatschen bzw, eine art peitschenhieb das wird wohl vom sonnenwind verursacht. Und zwar vorher war nicht mal
Klar dass sie überhaupt ein geräusch machen eine bedingung dafür ist aber auch dass eine bestimmte wetterlage auf der erde herrscht. Genannt wird sie
inversionswetterlage
Beispielsweise bei starkem frost dann ist es am boden kälter als in den luftschichten darüber in 70 metern
Höhe etwa liegt die trends schicht zwischen den. Warmen und den kalten luftmassen 170 meter am boden
Und genau hier sammeln sich all die geladenen teilchen von der erdoberfläche und wenn dann ungefähr 100 kilometern. Höhe ein polarlicht entsteht
Wechselwirken diese elektrisch. Geladenen teilchen mit den ionen in der luft die beteiligten forscher fanden außerdem heraus dass
Eine art entladung des magnetischen feldes passiert wenn die geladenen teilchen des sonnenwindes auf die erdatmosphäre treffen etwa
0,2 sekunden
Nach der magnetfeld änderung hatte das forschungsteam dieses klatschen der polarlichter aufnehmen können berechnet haben sie, dann dass die
geräuschquelle 70 bis 80 meter über dem boden liegen muss
Und das entspricht genau der sogenannten inversion schicht weil bei dieser
inversionswetterlage fakt eins polarlichter können fatale folgen für uns haben
Ja auch wenn es ein tolles naturspektakel ist es hat seine schattenseiten denn an den polarregionen schützt das eigene
Erdmagnetfeld weniger manche experten sagen dass es bei aktuellen
sonneneruptionen sinnvoll sei
Verkehrsflugzeuge andere. Routen fliegen zu lassen das machen sie auch. Außerdem können solche starken spannungsfeld
Auch die funktion von forschungs- und kommunikationssatelliten stören indem sie die messdaten oder signale zur erde stören in der alaska pipeline
hatten forschungsteams elektrische ströme von einigen 1000 ampere gemessen
Allein durch die wirkung des polarlicht das radio funk. Und satelliten navigation können ausfallen
genauso wie ganze stromnetze der schaden für die wirtschaft und infrastruktur
Ist jedes, mal enorm und beträgt schätzungen zufolge
48 milliarden us dollar täglich, und zwar nur in den usa
Und solche zwischenfälle hat es ja schon öfter gegeben wir haben hier ja schon
Darüber berichtet super sonnenstürme gefährden die erde den link zum video gibt es am ende dieses videos wenn
Er keine videos zu den drohnen gefahren durch sonnenstürme. Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
dann
Umgeht er die kaputte abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst keinen werfer papa passt kein video. Mehr
Denn über whatsapp erfahrt. Ihr von mir. Und noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
Einfach hier draufklicken, man, am besten
Auch meinen, schwesterkanal klicks, um, social and media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
Genau, die glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken super sonnenstürme treffen
unausweichlich die erde bis dann
bleibt dran